The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
So today, we're
going to talk about assembly
language and computer
architecture.
It's interesting these
days, most software courses
don't bother to talk
about these things.
And the reason is because
as much as possible people
have been insulated in writing
their software from performance
considerations.
But if you want to
write fast code,
you have to know what is
going on underneath so you
can exploit the strengths
of the architecture.
And the interface, the best
interface, that we have to that
is the assembly language.
So that's what we're
going to talk about today.
So when you take a
particular piece of code
like fib here, to compile
it you run it through Clang,
as I'm sure you're
familiar at this point.
And what it produces is
a binary machine language
that the computer is
hardware programmed
to interpret and execute.
It looks at the bits as
instructions as opposed to as
data.
And it executes them.
And that's what we
see when we execute.
This process is not one step.
It's actually there are
four stages to compilation;
preprocessing, compiling--
sorry, for the redundancy,
that's sort of a
bad name conflict,
but that's what they call it--
assembling and linking.
So I want to take us
through those stages.
So the first thing
that goes through
is you go through
a preprocess stage.
And you can invoke that
with Clang manually.
So you can say,
for example, if you
do clang minus e, that
will run the preprocessor
and nothing else.
And you can take a
look at the output
there and look to see how
all your macros got expanded
and such before the compilation
actually goes through.
Then you compile it.
And that produces assembly code.
So assembly is a mnemonic
structure of the machine code
that makes it more human
readable than the machine
code itself would be.
And once again, you can
produce the assembly yourself
with clang minus s.
And then finally,
penultimately maybe,
you can assemble that
assembly language code
to produce an object file.
And since we like to have
separate compilations,
you don't have to
compile everything
as one big monolithic hunk.
Then there's typically
a linking stage
to produce the final executable.
And for that we are using
ld for the most part.
We're actually using
the gold linker,
but ld is the command
that calls it.
So let's go through
each of those steps
and see what's going on.
So first, the preprocessing
is really straightforward.
So I'm not going to do that.
That's just a
textual substitution.
The next stage is the source
code to assembly code.
So when we do clang
minus s, we get
this symbolic representation.
And it looks something
like this, where we
have some labels on the side.
And we have some operations
when they have some directives.
And then we have a
lot of gibberish,
which won't seem like
so much gibberish
after you've played
with it a little bit.
But to begin with looks
kind of like gibberish.
From there, we assemble
that assembly code and that
produces the binary.
And once again, you can invoke
it just by running Clang.
Clang will recognize that it
doesn't have a C file or a C++
file.
It says, oh, goodness, I've
got an assembly language file.
And it will produce the binary.
Now, the other thing that
turns out to be the case
is because assembly
in machine code,
they're really very
similar in structure.
Just things like
the op codes, which
are the things that are
here in blue or purple,
whatever that color
is, like these guys,
those correspond to specific
bit patterns over here
in the machine code.
And these are the addresses
and the registers that we're
operating on, the operands.
Those correspond to other to
other bit codes over there.
And there's very much a--
it's not exactly one to one,
but it's pretty close one to one
compared to if you had C
and you look at the binary,
it's like way, way different.
So one of the things that turns
out you can do is if you have
the machine code, and especially
if the machine code that was
produced with so-called
debug symbols--
that is it was
compiled with dash g--
you can use this
program called objdump,
which will produce a
disassembly of the machine code.
So it will tell you, OK,
here's what the mnemonic, more
human readable code is, the
assembly code, from the binary.
And that's really
useful, especially
if you're trying to do things--
well, let's see why do we
bother looking at the assembly?
So why would you want to look
at the assembly of your program?
Does anybody have some ideas?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
made or not.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, you can see
whether certain optimizations
are made or not.
Other reasons?
Everybody is going
to say that one.
OK.
Another one is-- well, let's
see, so here's some reasons.
The assembly reveals what the
compiler did and did not do,
because you can see exactly what
the assembly is that is going
to be executed as machine code.
The second reason,
which turns out
to happen more often
you would think,
is that, hey, guess
what, compiler
is a piece of software.
It has bugs.
So your code isn't
operating correctly.
Oh, goodness, what's going on?
Maybe the compiler
made an error.
And we have certainly found
that, especially when you
start using some of the less
frequently used features
of a compiler.
You may discover,
oh, it's actually not
that well broken in.
And it mentions here you
may only have an effect when
compiling at -03, but if
you compile at -00, -01,
everything works out just fine.
So then it says, gee,
somewhere in the optimizations,
they did an optimization wrong.
So one of the first principles
of optimization is do it right.
And then the second
is make it fast.
And so sometimes the
compiler doesn't that.
It's also the case that
sometimes you cannot write code
that produces the
assembly that you want.
And in that case,
you can actually
write the assembly by hand.
Now, it used to be
many years ago--
many, many years ago--
that a lot of software
was written in assembly.
In fact, my first
job out of college,
I spent about half
the time programming
in assembly language.
And it's not as bad
as you would think.
But it certainly is easier
to have high-level languages
that's for sure.
You get lot more
done a lot quicker.
And the last reason
is reverse engineer.
You can figure out what a
program does when you only
have access to its
source, so, for example,
the matrix multiplication
example that I gave on day 1.
You know, we had the
overall outer structure,
but the inner loop, we could
not match the Intel math kernel
library code.
So what do we do?
We didn't have
the source for it.
We looked to see
what it was doing.
We said, oh, is that
what they're doing?
And then we're able
to do it ourselves
without having to get
the sauce from them.
So we reverse engineered
what they did?
So all those are good reasons.
Now, in this class, we
have some expectations.
So one thing is, you know,
assembly is complicated
and you needn't
memorize the manual.
In fact, the manual
has over 1,000 pages.
It's like-- but here's
what we do expect of you.
You should understand
how a compiler implements
various C linguistic constructs
with x86 instructions.
And that's what we'll
see in the next lecture.
And you should be able
to read x86 assembly
language with the aid of
an architecture manual.
And on a quiz, for example,
we would give you snippets
or explain what the op
codes that are being
used in case it's not there.
But you should have some
understanding of that,
so you can see what's
actually happening.
You should understand the
high-level performance
implications of common
assembly patterns.
OK, so what does it
mean to do things
in a particular way in
terms of performance?
So some of them
are quite obvious.
Vector operations
tend to be faster
than doing the same thing with
a bunch of scalar operations.
If you do write an assembly,
typically what we use
is there are a bunch of compiler
intrinsic functions, built-ins,
so-called, that allow you
to use the assembly language
instructions.
And you should be after we've
done this able to write code
from scratch if the
situation demands it sometime
in the future.
We won't do that in
this class, but we
expect that you will be in a
position to do that after--
you should get a
mastery to the level
where that would not be
impossible for you to do.
You'd be able to do that with
a reasonable amount of effort.
So the rest of the
lecture here is
I'm going to first start by
talking about the instruction
set architecture of
the x86-64, which
is the one that we are
using for the cloud machines
that we're using.
And then I'm going to talk
about floating point in vector
hardware and then I'm going
to do an overview of computer
architecture.
Now, all of this I'm doing--
this is software class, right?
Software performance
engineering we're doing.
So the reason
we're doing this is
so you can write code that
better matches the hardware,
therefore to better get it.
In order to do that, I could
give things at a high-level.
My experience is
that if you really
want to understand
something, you
want to understand it to
level that's necessary
and then one level below that.
It's not that you'll necessarily
use that one level below it,
but that gives you insight as
to why that layer is what it is
and what's really going on.
And so that's kind of
what we're going to do.
We're going to do
a dive that takes
us one level beyond
what you probably
will need to know in
the class, so that you
have a robust foundation
for understanding.
Does that makes sense?
That's my part of my
learning philosophy
is you know go one step beyond.
And then you can come back.
The ISA primer, so the ISA talks
about the syntax and semantics
of assembly.
There are four
important concepts
in the instruction
set architecture--
the notion of registers,
the notion of instructions,
the data types, and the
memory addressing modes.
And those are sort of indicated.
For example, here, we're going
to go through those one by one.
So let's start
with the registers.
So the registers is where
the processor stores things.
And there are a bunch
of x86 registers,
so many that you don't
need to know most of them.
The ones that are
important are these.
So first of all, there a
general purpose registers.
And those typically
have width 64.
And there are many of those.
There is a so-called flags
register, called RFLAGS,
which keeps track of
things like whether there
was an overflow, whether
the last arithmetic
operation resulted in a
zero, whether a kid there
was a carryout of a
word or what have you.
The next one is the
instruction pointer.
So the assembly
language is organized
as a sequence of instructions.
And the hardware
marches linearly
through that sequence,
one after the other,
unless it encounters
a conditional jump
or an unconditional
jump, in which case
it'll branch to whatever
the location is.
But for the most part,
it's just running straight
through memory.
Then there are
some registers that
were added quite late in the
game, namely the SSE registers
and the AVX registers.
And these are vector registers.
So the XMM registers were, when
they first did vectorization,
they used 128 bits.
There's also for AVX, there
are the YMM registers.
And in the most
recent processors,
which were not using
this term, there's
another level of AVX that
gives you 512-bit registers.
Maybe we'll use that
for the final project,
because it's just like a little
more power for the game playing
project.
But for most of what
you'll be doing,
we'll just be keeping to
the C4 instances in AWS
that you guys have been using.
Now, the x86-64 didn't
start out as x86-64.
It started out as x86.
And it was used for machines,
in particular the 80-86,
which had a 16-bit word.
So really short.
How many things can you
index with a 16-bit word?
About how many?
AUDIENCE: 65,000.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, about 65,000.
65,536 words you can
address, or bytes.
This is byte addressing.
So that's 65k bytes
that you can address.
How could they possibly
use that for machines?
Well, the answer is that's how
much memory was on the machine.
You didn't have gigabytes.
So as the machines--
as Moore's law marched along
and we got more and more memory,
then the words had to become
wider to be able to index them.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, but here's
the thing is if you're building
stuff that's too expensive
and you can't get memory
that's big enough, then
if you build a wider word, like
if you build a word of 32 bits,
then your processor
just cost twice as much
as the next guy's processor.
So instead, what they did is
they went along as long as that
was the common size, and
then had some growth pains
and went to 32.
And from there, they had
some more growth pains
and went to 64.
OK, those are two
separate things.
And, in fact, they did they
did some really weird stuff.
So what they did in fact is
when they made these longer
registers, they have
registers that are
aliased to exactly the same
thing for the lower bits.
So they can address
them either by a byte--
so these registers
all have the same--
you can do the lower and
upper half of the short word,
or you can do the 32-bit word
or you can do the 64-bit word.
And that's just like if
you're doing this today,
you wouldn't do that.
You wouldn't have all these
registers that alias and such.
But that's what they did because
this is history, not design.
And the reason was
because when they're
doing that they were not
designing for long term.
Now, are we going to go
to 128-bit addressing?
Probably not.
64 bits address is a
spectacular amount of stuff.
You know, not quite as many--
2 to the 64th is what?
Is like how many gazillions?
It's a lot of gazillions.
So, yeah, we're not going to
have to go beyond 64 probably.
So here are the general
purpose registers.
And as I mentioned, they
have different names,
but they cover the same thing.
So if you change eax, for
example, that also changes rax.
And so you see they originally
all had functional purposes.
Now, they're all pretty
much the same thing,
but the names have stuck
because of history.
Instead of calling
them registers
0, register 1, or whatever,
they all have these funny names.
Some of them still are used
for a particular purpose,
like rsp is used as
the stack pointer.
And rbp is used to point
to the base of the frame,
for those who remember
their 6004 stuff.
So anyway, there are
a whole bunch of them.
And they're different
names depending
upon which part of the
register you're accessing.
Now, the format of an
x86-64 instruction code
is to have an opcode and
then an operand list.
And the operand list is
typically 0, 1, 2, or rarely
3 operands separated by commas.
Typically, all
operands are sources
and one operand might
also be the destination.
So, for example, if you take a
look at this add instruction,
the operation is an add.
And the operand list
is these two registers.
One is edi and the other is ecx.
And the destination
is the second one.
When you add-- in this
case, what's going on
is it's taking the value in
ecx, adding the value in edi
into it.
And the result is in ecx.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there a convention
for where the destination
[INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Funny you should ask.
Yes.
So what does op A, B mean?
It turns out naturally
that the literature
is inconsistent about how
it refers to operations.
And there's two major
ways that are used.
One is the AT&T syntax, and
the other is the Intel syntax.
So the AT&T syntax, the second
operand is the destination.
The last operand
is the destination.
In the Intel syntax, the first
operand is the destination.
OK, is that confusing?
So almost all the tools
that we're going to use
are going to use
the AT&T syntax.
But you will read documentation,
which is Intel documentation.
It will use the other syntax.
Don't get confused.
OK?
I can't help-- it's
like I can't help
that this is the way the
state of the world is.
OK?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are there tools
that help [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Oh, yeah.
In particular, if you
could compile it and undo,
but I'm sure there's--
I mean, this is not a
hard translation thing.
I'll bet if you just Google,
you can in two minutes,
in two seconds, find
somebody who will translate
from one to the other.
This is not a complicated
translation process.
Now, here are some very
common x86 opcodes.
And so let me just
mention a few of these,
because these are ones that
you'll often see in the code.
So move, what do
you think move does?
AUDIENCE: Moves something.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah,
it puts something in one
register into another register.
Of course, when
it moves it, this
is computer science
move, not real move.
When I move my belongings
in my house to my new house,
they're no longer in
the old place, right?
But in computer science, for
some reason, when we move
things we leave a copy behind.
So they may call it move, but--
AUDIENCE: Why don't
they call it copy?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah,
why don't they call it copy?
You got me.
OK, then there's
conditional move.
So this is move based
on a condition--
and we'll see some of
the ways that this is--
like move if flag is equal
to 0 and so forth, so
basically conditional move.
It doesn't always do the move.
Then you can extend the sign.
So, for example, suppose you're
moving from a 32-bit value
register into a 64-bit register.
Then the question is, what
happens to high order bits?
So there's two basic
mechanisms that can be used.
Either it can be
filled with zeros,
or remember that the first
bit, or the leftmost bit as we
think of it, is the sign bit
from our electron binary.
That bit will be extended
through the high order
part of the word, so that the
whole number if it's negative
will be negative and
if it's positive,
it'll be zeros and so forth.
Does that makes sense?
Then there are things like
push and pop to do stacks.
There's a lot of
integer arithmetic.
There's addition, subtraction,
multiplication, division,
various shifts, address
calculation shifts, rotations,
incrementing, decrementing,
negating, etc.
There's also a lot of binary
logic, AND, OR, XOR, NOT.
Those are all doing
bitwise operations.
And then there is Boolean
logic, like testing
to see whether some value has
a given value or comparing.
There's unconditional
jump, which is jump.
And there's conditional jumps,
which is jump with a condition.
And then things
like subroutines.
And there are a bunch more,
which the manual will have
and which will
undoubtedly show up.
Like, for example, there's the
whole set of vector operations
we'll talk about a
little bit later.
Now, the opcodes
may be augmented
with a suffix that describes
the data type of the operation
or a condition code.
OK, so an opcode for data
movement, arithmetic, or logic
use a single character suffix
to indicate the data type.
And if the suffix is missing,
it can usually be inferred.
So take a look at this example.
So this is a move
with a q at the end.
What do you think q stands for?
AUDIENCE: Quad words?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Quad word.
OK, how many bytes
in a quad word?
AUDIENCE: Eight.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Eight.
That's because originally it
started out with a 16-bit word.
So they said a quad word was
four of those 16-bit words.
So that's 8 bytes.
You get the idea, right?
But let me tell you this is all
over the x86 instruction set.
All these historical
things and all these
mnemonics that if you don't
understand what they really
mean, you can get very confused.
So in this case, we're
moving a 64-bit integer,
because a quad word
has 8 bytes or 64 bits.
This is one of my--
it's like whenever I
prepare this lecture,
I just go into spasms
of laughter, as I look
and I say, oh, my god,
they really did that like.
For example, on the last
page, when I did subtract.
So the sub-operator, if it's
a two argument operator,
it subtracts the--
I think it's the
first and the second.
But there is no way of
subtracting the other way
around.
It puts the destination
in the second one.
It basically takes the second
one minus the first one
and puts that in the second one.
But if you wanted to have
it the other way around,
to save yourself a cycle--
anyway, it doesn't matter.
You can't do it that way.
And all this stuff the
compiler has to understand.
So here are the
x86-64 data types.
The way I've done it is to show
you the difference between C
and x86-64, so for example,
here are the declarations in C.
So there's a char, a short,
int, unsigned int, long, etc.
Here's an example
of a C constant
that does those things.
And here's the size
in bytes that you
get when you declare that.
And then the assembly suffix
is one of these things.
So in the assembly, it says
b or w for a word, an l or d
for a double word, a q
for a quad word, i.e.
8 bytes, single precision,
double precision,
extended precision.
So sign extension use
two date type suffixes.
So here's an example.
So the first one says
we're going to move.
And now you see I can't read
this without my cheat sheet.
So what is this saying?
This is saying, we're going
to move with a zero-extend.
And it's going to be the
first operand is a byte,
and the second
operation is a long.
Is that right?
If I'm wrong, it's like I
got to look at the chart too.
And, of course, we
don't hold you to that.
But the z there says
extends with zeros.
And the S says
preserve the sign.
So that's the things.
Now, that would all
be all well and good,
except that then what they did
is if you do 32-bit operations,
where you're moving
it to a 64-bit value,
it implicitly
zero-extends the sign.
If you do it for smaller
values and you store it in,
it simply overwrites the
values in those registers.
It doesn't touch
the high order bits.
But when they did the
32 to 64-bit extension
of the instruction
set, they decided
that they wouldn't do what
had been done in the past.
And they decided that they
would zero-extend things,
unless there was something
explicit to the contrary.
You got me, OK.
Yeah, I have a friend
who worked at Intel.
And he had a joke about
the Intel instructions set.
You'll discover the
Intel instruction
set is really complicated.
He says, here's the idea of
the Intel instruction set.
He said, to become
an Intel fellow,
you need to have an instruction
in the Intel instruction set.
You have an instruction
that you invented
and that that's
now used in Intel.
He says nobody becomes
an Intel fellow
for removing instructions.
So it just sort of grows and
grows and grows and gets more
and more complicated
for each thing.
Now, once again, for
extension, you can sign-extend.
And here's two examples.
In one case, moving an 8-bit
integer to a 32-bit integer
and zero-extended it
versus preserving the sign.
Conditional jumps
and conditional moves
also use suffixes to
indicate the condition code.
So here, for example, the ne
indicates the jump should only
be taken if the argument
of the previous comparison
are not equal.
So ne is not equal.
So you do a
comparison, and that's
going to set a flag in
the RFLAGS register.
Then the jump will
look at that flag
and decide whether it's going
to jump or not or just continue
the sequential
execution of the code.
And there are a bunch
of things that you can
jump on which are status flags.
And you can see the names here.
There's Carry.
There's Parity.
Parity is the XOR of all
the bits in the word.
Adjust, I don't even
know what that's for.
There's the Zero flag.
It tells whether it's a zero.
There's a Sign flag, whether
it's positive or negative.
There's a Trap flag and
Interrupt enable and Direction,
Overflow.
So anyway, you can see there
are a whole bunch of these.
So, for example here, this
is going to decrement rbx.
And then it sets the Zero
flag if the results are equal.
And then the jump,
the conditional jump,
jumps to the label if the ZF
flag is not set, in this case.
OK, it make sense?
After a fashion.
Doesn't make rational sense,
but it does make sense.
Here are the main ones
that you're going to need.
The Carry flag is whether you
got a carry or a borrow out
of the most significant bit.
The Zero flag is if the
ALU operation was 0,
whether the last ALU operation
had the sign bit set.
And the overflow
says it resulted
in arithmetic overflow.
The condition codes are--
if you put one of
these condition codes
on your conditional
jump or whatever,
this tells you exactly what
the flag is that is being set.
So, for example, the easy
ones are if it's equal.
But there are some
other ones there.
So, for example, if you
say why, for example,
do the condition codes e
and ne, check the Zero flag?
And the answer is
typically, rather
than having a separate
comparison, what they've done
is separate the branch
from the comparison itself.
But it also needn't be
a compare instruction.
It could be the result
of the last arithmetic
operation was a zero,
and therefore it
can branch without having to
do a comparison with zero.
So, for example,
if you have a loop.
where you're decrementing a
counter till it gets to 0,
that's actually faster
by one instruction
to compare whether
the loop index hits 0
than it is if you have the
loop going up to n, and then
every time through the loop
having to compare with n
in order before you can branch.
So these days that optimization
doesn't mean anything,
because, as we'll talk
about in a little bit,
these machines are so powerful,
that doing an extra integer
arithmetic like
that probably has
no bearing on the overall cost.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So this instruction
doesn't take arguments?
It just looks at the flags?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Just
looks at the flags, yep.
Just looks at the flags.
It doesn't take any arguments.
Now, the next aspect of this
is you can give registers,
but you also can address memory.
And there are three direct
addressing modes and three
indirect addressing modes.
At most, one operand may
specify a memory address.
So here are the direct
addressing modes.
So for immediate what you do
is you give it a constant,
like 172, random constant,
to store into the register,
in this case.
That's called an immediate.
What happens if you
look at the instruction,
if you look at the
machine language,
172 is right in the instruction.
It's right in the
instruction, that number 172.
Register says we'll move
the value from the register,
in this case, %cx.
And then the index of the
register is put in that part.
And direct memory says use a
particular memory location.
And you can give a hex value.
When you do direct
memory, it's going
to use the value at
that place in memory.
And to indicate that memory
is going to take you,
on a 64-bit machine, 64
8-bytes to specify that memory.
Whereas, for example, the move
q, 172 will fit in 1 byte.
And so I'll have spent a lot
less storage in order to do it.
Plus, I can do it directly
from the instruction stream.
And I avoid having
an access to memory,
which is very expensive.
So how many cycles does it
take if the value that you're
fetching from memory
is not in cache
or whatever or a register?
If I'm fetching
something from memory,
how many cycles of
the machine does
it typically take these days.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A few hundred?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, a
couple of hundred or more,
yeah, a couple hundred cycles.
To fetch something from memory.
It's so slow.
No, it's the
processors are so fast.
And so clearly, if you can
get things into registers,
most registers you can
access in a single cycle.
So we want to move things
close to the processor,
operate on them,
shove them back.
And while we pull
things from memory,
we want other things
to be to be working on.
And so the hardware is
all organized to do that.
Now, of course, we
spend a lot of time
fetching stuff from memory.
And that's one reason
we use caching.
And we'll have a big thing--
caching is really important.
We're going spend
a bunch of time
on how to get the best
out of your cache.
There's also
indirect addressing.
So instead of just
giving a location,
you say, oh, let's go
to some other place,
for example, a register,
and get the value
and the address is going to
be stored in that location.
So, for example here, register
indirect says, in this case,
move the contents of rax into--
sorry, the contents is
the address of the thing
that you're going
to move into rdi.
So if rax was
location 172, then it
would take whatever is in
location 172 and put it in rdi.
Registered index says,
well, do the same thing,
but while you're at
it, add an offset.
So once again, if rax
had 172, in this case
it would go to 344 to
fetch the value out
of that location 344 for
this particular instruction.
And then instruction-pointer
relative,
instead of indexing off
of a general purpose
register, you index off
the instruction pointer.
That usually happens in the
code where the code is--
for example, you
can jump to where
you are in the code
plus four instructions.
So you can jump down some number
of instructions in the code.
Usually, you'll see that
only with use with control,
because you're
talking about things.
But sometimes they'll put some
data in the instruction stream.
And then it can index off
the instruction pointer
to get those values
without having
to soil another register.
Now, the most general form is
base indexed scale displacement
addressing.
Wow.
This is a move that has a
constant plus three terms.
And this is the most complicated
instruction that is supported.
The mode refers to the
address whatever the base is.
So the base is a general purpose
register, in this case, rdi.
And then it adds the
index times the scale.
So the scale is 1, 2, 4, or 8.
And then a displacement, which
is that number on the front.
And this gives you
very general indexing
of things off of a base point.
You'll often see this
kind of accessing
when you're accessing
stack memory,
because everything
you can say, here
is the base of my frame on the
stack, and now for anything
that I want to add, I'm going
to be going up a certain amount.
I may scaling by
a certain amount
to get the value that I want.
So once again, you will
become familiar with a manual.
You don't have to
memorize all these,
but you do have to
understand that there
are a lot of these
complex addressing modes.
The jump instruction
take a label
as their operand,
which identifies
a location in the code.
For this, the labels
can be symbols.
In other words, you
can say here's a symbol
that I want to jump to.
It might be the
beginning of a function,
or it might be a
label that's generated
to be at the beginning
of a loop or whatever.
They can be exact addresses--
go to this place in the code.
Or they can be relative
address-- jump to some place
as I mentioned that's indexed
off the instruction pointer.
And then an indirect
jump takes as its
operand an indirect address--
oop, I got-- as its
operand as its operand.
OK, so that's a typo.
It just takes an operand
as an indirect address.
So basically, you can
say, jump to whatever
is pointed to by that register
using whatever indexing method
that you want.
So that's kind of the overview
of the assembly language.
Now, let's take a
look at some idioms.
So the XOR opcode computes
the bitwise XOR of A and B.
We saw XOR was a great
trick for swapping numbers,
for example, the other day.
So often in the code,
you will see something
like this, xor rax rax.
What does that do?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Zeros the register.
CHARLES LEISERSON: It
zeros the register.
Why does that zero the register?
AUDIENCE: Is the
XOR just the same?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, it's basically
taking the results of rax,
the results rax, xor-ing them.
And when you XOR
something with itself,
you get zero, storing
that back into it.
So that's actually
how you zero things.
So you'll see that.
Whenever you see that,
hey, what are they doing?
They're zeroing the register.
And that's actually
quicker and easier
than having a zero constant that
they put into the instruction.
It saves a byte,
because this ends up
being a very short instruction.
I don't remember how many
bytes that instruction is.
Here's another one, the
test opcode, test A, B,
computes the bitwise AND of A
and B and discards the result,
preserving the RFLAGS register.
So basically, it says, what
does the test instruction
for these things do?
So what is the first one doing?
So it takes rcx-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does it jump?
It jumps to [INAUDIBLE]
rcx [INAUDIBLE]
So it takes the
bitwise AND of A and B.
And so then it's
saying jump if equal.
So--
AUDIENCE: An AND would
be non-zero in any
of the bits set.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Right.
AND is non-zero if any
of the bits are set.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So if the zero flag were set,
that means that rcx was zero.
CHARLES LEISERSON: That's right.
So if the Zero flag is
set, then rcx is set.
So this is going to
jump to that location
if rcx holds the value 0.
In all the other cases,
it won't set the Zero flag
because the result
of the AND will be 0.
So once again, that's kind
of an idiom that they use.
What about the second one?
So this is a conditional move.
So both of them are
basically checking
to see if the register is 0.
And then doing something
if it is or isn't.
But those are just
idioms that you sort of
have to look at to see how
it is that they accomplish
their particular thing.
Here's another one.
So the ISA can include
several no-op, no operation
instructions, including
nop, nop A-- that's
an operation with an argument--
and data16, which sets aside
2 bytes of a nop.
So here's a line
of assembly that we
found in some of our code--
data16 days16 data16
nopw and then %csx.
So nopw is going to take this
argument, which has got all
this address calculation in it.
So what do you
think this is doing?
What's the effect
of this, by the way?
They're all no-ops.
So the effect is?
Nothing.
The effect is nothing.
OK, now it does set the RFLAGS.
But basically, mostly,
it does nothing.
Why would a compiler generate
assembly with these idioms?
Why would you get that kind of--
that's crazy, right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could it be doing
some cache optimization?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, it's actually
doing alignment optimization
typically or code size.
So it may want to start the next
instruction on the beginning
of a cache line.
And, in fact, there's
a directive to do that.
If you want all your
functions to start
at the beginning
of cache line, then
it wants to make sure that
if code gets to that point,
you'll just proceed to
jump through memory,
continue through memory.
So mainly is to optimize memory.
So you'll see those things.
I mean, you just
have to realize, oh,
that's the compiler
generating some sum no-ops.
So that's sort of
our brief excursion
over assembly language,
x86 assembly language.
Now, I want to dive into
floating-point and vector
hardware, which is going
to be the main part.
And then if there's any time at
the end, I'll show the slides--
I have a bunch of other slides
on how branch prediction works
and a variety of other
machines sorts of things,
that if we don't get
to, it's no problem.
You can take a
look at the slides,
and there's also the
architecture manual.
So floating-point
instruction sets,
so mostly the scalar
floating-point operations
are access via couple of
different instruction sets.
So the history of floating
point is interesting,
because originally the 80-86 did
not have a floating-point unit.
Floating-point was
done in software.
And then they made
a companion chip
that would do floating-point.
And then they
started integrating
and so forth as
miniaturization took hold.
So the SSE and AVX
instructions do
both single and double precision
scalar floating-point, i.e.
floats or doubles.
And then the x86 instructions,
the x87 instructions--
that's the 80-87 that
was attached to the 80-86
and that's where they get them--
support single, double,
and extended precision
scalar floating-point
arithmetic,
including float double
and long double.
So you can actually get a
great big result of a multiply
if you use the x87
instruction sets.
And they also include
vector instructions,
so you can multiply
or add there as well--
so all these places on the
chip where you can decide
to do one thing or another.
Compilers generally like
the SSE instructions
over the x87 instructions
because they're simpler
to compile for and to optimize.
And the SSE opcodes are similar
to the normal x86 opcodes.
And they use the XMM registers
and floating-point types.
And so you'll see stuff
like this, where you've
got a movesd and so forth.
The suffix there is
saying what the data type.
In this case, it's saying it's a
double precision floating-point
value, i.e. a double.
Once again, they're
using suffix.
The sd in this case is a double
precision floating-point.
The other option
is the first letter
says whether it's single, i.e.
a scalar operation, or packed,
i.e. a vector operation.
And the second letter
says whether it's
single or double precision.
And so when you see one of these
operations, you can decode,
oh, this is operating on a
64-bit value or a 32-bit value,
floating-point value, or on
a vector of those values.
Now, what about these vectors?
So when you start using
the packed representation
and you start using
vectors, you have
to understand a little bit
about the vector units that
are on these machines.
So the way a vector
unit works is
that there is the processor
issuing instructions.
And it issues the instructions
to all of the vector units.
So for example, if you take
a look at a typical thing,
you may have a vector
width of four vector units.
Each of them is
often called a lane--
l-a-n-e.
And the x is the vector width.
And so when the
instruction is given,
it's given to all
of the vector units.
And they all do it on their
own local copy of the register.
So the register you can think
of as a very wide thing broken
into several words.
And when I say add
two vectors together,
it'll add four words
together and store it back
into another vector register.
And so whatever k is--
in the example I
just said, k was 4.
And the lanes are the
thing that each of which
contains the integer
floating-point arithmetic.
But the important thing is that
they all operate in lock step.
It's not like one is
going to do one thing
and another is going
to do another thing.
They all have to do
exactly the same thing.
And the basic idea here is for
the price of one instruction,
I can command a bunch of
operations to be done.
Now, generally,
vector instructions
operate in an
element-wise fashion,
where you take the i-th
element of one vector
and operate on it with the
i-th element of another vector.
And all the lanes perform
exactly the same operation.
Depending upon the architecture,
some architectures,
the operands need to be aligned.
That is you've got to have
the beginnings at the exactly
same place in memory, a
multiple of the vector length.
There are others
where the vectors
can be shifted in memory.
Usually, there's a performance
difference between the two.
If it does support--
some of them
will not support unaligned
vector operations.
So if it can't figure out that
they're aligned, I'm sorry,
your code will end up
being executed scalar,
in a scalar fashion.
If they are aligned, it's got
to be able to figure that out.
And in that case--
sorry, if it's not
aligned, but you
do support vector
operizations unaligned,
it's usually slower than
if they are aligned.
And for some machines
now, they actually
have good performance on both.
So it really depends
upon the machine.
And then also there
are some architectures
will support cross-lane
operation, such as inserting
or extracting subsets
of vector elements,
permuting, shuffling, scatter,
gather types of operations.
So x86 supports several
instruction sets,
as I mentioned.
There's SSE.
There's AVX.
There's AVX2.
And then there's
now the AVX-512,
or sometimes called
AVX3, which is not
available on the machines
that we'll be using,
the Haswell machines
that we'll be doing.
Generally, the AVX and AVX2
extend the SSE instruction
set by using the wider
registers and operate on a 2.
The SSE use wider
registers and operate
on at most two operands.
The AVX ones can use the 256 and
also have three operands, not
just two operations.
So say you can say add A
to B and store it in C,
as opposed to saying add
A to B and store it in B.
So it can also support three.
Yeah, most of them are
similar to traditional opcodes
with minor differences.
So if you look at them,
if you have an SSE,
it basically looks just
like the traditional name,
like add in this case,
but you can then say,
do a packed add or a
vector with packed data.
So the v prefix it's AVX.
So if you see it's
v, you go to the part
in the manual that says AVX.
If you see the p's, that
say it's packed data.
Then you go to SSE if
it doesn't have the v.
And the p prefix distinguishing
integer vector instruction,
you got me.
I tried to think why is p
distinguishing an integer?
It's like p, good mnemonic
for integer, right?
Then in addition, they do
this aliasing trick again,
where the YMM registers actually
alias the XMM registers.
So you can use both
operations, but you've
got to be careful
what's going on,
because they just extended them.
And now, of course,
with AVX-512,
they did another
extension to 512 bits.
That's vectors stuff.
So you can use those explicitly.
The compiler will
vectorize for you.
And the homework this week takes
you through some vectorization
exercises.
It's actually a lot of fun.
We were just going over
it in a staff meeting.
And it's really fun.
I think it's a
really fun exercise.
We introduced that
last year, by the way,
or maybe two years ago.
But, in any case,
it's a fun one--
for my definition
of fun, which I hope
is your definition of fun.
Now, I want to talk generally
about computer architecture.
And I'm not going to get through
all of these slides, as I say.
But I want to get started
on the and give you
a sense of other things
going on in the processor
that you should be aware of.
So in 6.004, you probably talked
about a 5-stage processor.
Anybody remember that?
OK, 5-stage processor.
There's an Instruction Fetch.
There's an Instruction Decode.
There's an Execute.
Then there's a
Memory Addressing.
And then you Write
back the values.
And this is done as
a pipeline, so as
to make-- you could do
all of this in one thing,
but then you have
a long clock cycle.
And you'll only be able
to do one thing at a time.
Instead, they stack
them together.
So here's a block diagram
of the 5-stage processor.
We read the
instruction from memory
in the instruction fetch cycle.
Then we decode it.
Basically, it takes
a look at, what
is the opcode, what are the
addressing modes, et cetera,
and figures out what
it actually has to do
and actually performs
the ALU operations.
And then it reads and
writes the data memory.
And then it writes back
the results into registers.
That's typically a common
way that these things
go for a 5-stage processor.
By the way, this is
vastly oversimplified.
You can take 6823 if
you want to learn truth.
I'm going to tell you
nothing but white lies
for this lecture.
Now, if you look at the
Intel Haswell, the machine
that we're using, it actually
has between 14 and 19 pipeline
stages.
The 14 to 19 reflects
the fact that there
are different paths
through it that
take different amounts of time.
It also I think
reflects a little bit
that nobody has published
the Intel internal stuff.
So maybe we're not sure if
it's 14 to 19, but somewhere
in that range.
But I think it's actually
because the different lengths
of time as I was explaining.
So what I want to do is--
you've seen the
5-stage price line.
I want to talk about the
difference between that
and a modern processor by
looking at several design
features.
We already talked
about vector hardware.
I then want to talk
about super scalar
processing, out of
order execution,
and branch prediction
a little bit.
And the out of order, I'm
going to skip a bunch of that
because it has to do with
score boarding, which
is really interesting and fun,
but it's also time consuming.
But it's really
interesting and fun.
That's what you learn in 6823.
So historically,
there's two ways
that people make
processors go faster--
by exploiting parallelism
and by exploiting locality.
And parallelism, there's
instruction-- well,
we already did
word-level parallelism
in the bit tricks thing.
But there's also
instruction-level parallelism,
so-called ILB,
vectorization and multicore.
And for locality, the main thing
that's used there is caching.
I would say also
the fact that you
have a design with registers
that also reflects locality,
because the way that the
processor wants to do things
is fetch stuff from memory.
It doesn't want to
operate on it in memory.
That's very expensive.
It wants to fetch things into
memory, get enough of them
there that you can
do some calculations,
do a whole bunch
of calculations,
and then put them
back out there.
So this lecture we're talking
about ILP and vectorization.
So let me talk about
instruction-level parallelism.
So when you have, let's
say, a 5-stage pipeline,
you're interested in
finding opportunities
to execute multiple
instruction simultaneously.
So in instruction 1, it's going
to do an instruction fetch.
Then it does its decode.
And so it takes five cycles for
this instruction to complete.
So ideally what you'd
like is that you
can start instruction 2 on cycle
2, instruction 3 on cycle 3,
and so forth, and have 5
instructions-- once you
get into the steady state,
have 5 instructions executing
all the time.
That would be ideal, where
each one takes just one thing.
So that's really pretty good.
And that would improve
the throughput.
Even though it might
take a long time
to get one instruction done,
I can have many instructions
in the pipeline at some time.
So each pipeline is executing
a different instruction.
However, in practice
this isn't what happens.
In practice, you
discover that there are
what's called pipeline stalls.
When it comes time to
execute an instruction,
for some correctness reason, it
cannot execute the instruction.
It has to wait.
And that's a pipeline stall.
That's what you
want to try to avoid
and the compiler tries to Bruce
code that will avoid stalls.
So why do stalls happen?
They happen because of
what are called hazards.
There's actually two
notions of hazard.
And this is one of them.
The other is a race
condition hazard.
This is dependency hazard.
But people call
them both hazards,
just like they call the second
stage of compilation compiling.
It's like they make
up these words.
So here's three types of
hazards that can prevent
an instruction from executing.
First of all, there's what's
called a structural hazard.
Two instructions attempt to
use the same functional unit,
the same time.
If there's, for example, only
one floating-point multiplier
and two of them try to use it at
the same time, one has to wait.
In modern processors, there's
a bunch of each of those.
But if you have k functional
units and k plus 1 instructions
want to access it,
you're out of luck.
One of them is going
to have to wait.
The second is a data hazard.
This is when an
instruction depends
on the result of a prior
instruction in the pipeline.
So one instruction is
computing a value that
is going to stick in rcx, say.
So they stick it into rcx.
The other one has to
read the value from rcx
and it comes later.
That other instruction
has to wait
until that value is written
there before it can read it.
That's a data hazard.
And a control
hazard is where you
decide that you
need to make a jump
and you can't execute
the next instruction,
because you don't know which
way the jump is going to go.
So if you have a
conditional jump,
it's like, well, what's the next
instruction after that jump?
I don't know.
So I have to wait
to execute that.
I can't go ahead and
do the jump and then do
the next instruction after
it, because I don't know what
happened to the previous one.
Now of these, we're going to
mostly talk about data hazards.
So an instruction can
create a data hazard--
I can create a data hazard
due to a dependence between i
and j.
So the first type is
called a true dependence,
or I read after
write dependence.
And this is where,
as in this example,
I'm adding something
and storing into rax
and the next instruction
wants to read from rax.
So the second
instruction can't get
going until the
previous one or it may
stall until the result of
the previous one is known.
There's another one
called an anti-dependence.
This is where I want to
write into a location,
but I have to wait until the
previous instruction has read
the value, because
otherwise I'm going
to clobber that
instruction and clobber
the value before it gets read.
so that's an anti-dependence.
And then the final one
is an output dependence,
where they're both trying to
move something to are rax.
So why would two things
want to move things
to the same location?
After all, one of them is going
to be lost and just not do
that instruction.
Why wouldn't--
AUDIENCE: Set some flags.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, maybe because it
wants to set some flags.
So that's one reason
that it might do this,
because you know the
first instruction set
some flags in addition to moving
the output to that location.
And there's one other reason.
What's the other reason?
I'm blanking.
There's two reasons.
And I didn't put
them in my notes.
I don't remember.
OK, but anyway, that's a
good question for quiz then.
OK, give me two reasons-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can there be
intermediate instructions
like between those [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: There
could, but of course
then if it's going to
use that register, then--
oh, I know the other reason.
So this is still
good for a quiz.
The other reason is there
may be aliasing going on.
Maybe an intervening
instruction uses one
of the values in its aliasist.
So uses part of the result
or whatever, there still
could be a dependency.
Anyway, some
arithmetic operations
are complex to
implement in hardware
and have long latencies.
So here's some sample opcodes
and how many latency they take.
They take a different number.
So, for example, integer
division actually is variable,
but a multiply takes
about three times what
most of the integer
operations are.
And floating-point
multiply is like 5.
And then fma, what's fma?
Fused multiply add.
This is where you're doing
both a multiply and an add.
And why do we care about
fuse multiply adds?
AUDIENCE: For memory
accessing and [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Not
for memory accessing.
This is actually floating-point
multiply and add.
It's called linear algebra.
So when you do major
multiplication,
you're doing dot product.
You're doing
multiplies and adds.
So that kind of thing, that's
where you do a lot of those.
So how does the
hardware accommodate
these complex operations?
So the strategy that much
hardware tends to use
is to have separate functional
units for complex operations,
such as floating-point
arithmetic.
So there may be in fact
separate registers,
for example, the XMM
registers, that only
work with the floating point.
So you have your basic
5-stage pipeline.
You have another pipeline
that's off on the side.
And it's going to take
multiple cycles sometimes
for things and maybe pipeline
to a different depth.
And so you basically
separate these operations.
The functional units
may be pipelined, fully,
partially, or not at all.
And so I now have a whole bunch
of different functional units,
and there's different
paths that I'm
going to be able to take through
the data path of the processor.
So in Haswell, they have
integer vector floating-point
distributed among eight
different ports, which
is sort from the entry.
So given that, things
get really complicated.
If we go back to
our simple diagram,
suppose we have all these
additional functional units,
how can I now exploit more
instruction-level parallelism?
So right now, we can start
up one operation at a time.
What might I do to get more
parallelism out of the hardware
that I've got?
What do you think
computer architects did?
OK.
AUDIENCE: It's a guess but, you
could glue together [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, so
even simpler than that, but
which is implied in
what you're saying,
is you can just fetch and
issue multiple instructions
per cycle.
So rather than just
doing one per cycle
as we showed with a
typical pipeline processor,
let me fetch several
that use different parts
of the processor pipeline,
because they're not
going to interfere, to
keep everything busy.
And so that's basically
what's called a super scalar
processor, where it's not
executing one thing at a time.
It's executing multiple
things at a time.
So Haswell, in fact,
breaks up the instructions
into simpler operations,
called micro-ops.
And they can emit for
micro-ops per cycle
to the rest of the pipeline.
And the fetch and decode
stages implement optimizations
on micro-op processing,
including special cases
for common patents.
For example, if it sees
the XOR of rax and rax,
it knows that rax
is being set to 0.
It doesn't even use a
functional unit for that.
It just does it and it's done.
It has just a special
logic that observes
that because it's such a
common thing to set things out.
And so that means that now
your processor can execute
a lot of things at one time.
And that's the machines
that you're doing.
That's why when I said if
you save one add instruction,
it probably doesn't
make any difference
in today's processor,
because there's probably
an idle adder lying around.
There's probably a-- did
I read caught how many--
where do we go here?
Yeah, so if you look
here, you can even
discover that there are
actually a bunch of ALUs that
are capable of doing an add.
So they're all over
the map in Haswell.
Now, still, we are insisting
that the processors execute
in things in order.
And that's kind of the
next stage is, how do you
end up making things run--
that is, how do you make it
so that you can free yourself
from the tyranny of one
instruction after the other?
And so the first
thing is there's
a strategy called bypassing.
So suppose that you have
instructions running into rax.
And then you're going
to use that to read.
Well, why bother waiting for it
to be stored into the register
file and then pulled back out
for the second instruction?
Instead, let's have a
bypass, a special circuit
that identifies that
kind of situation
and feeds it directly
to the next instruction
without requiring that it
go into the register file
and back out.
So that's called bypassing.
There are lots of places
where things are bypassed.
And we'll talk about it more.
So normally, you
would stall waiting
for it to be written back.
And now, when you
eliminate it, now I
can move it way
forward, because I just
use the bypass path to execute.
And it allows the
second instruction
to get going earlier.
What else can we do?
Well, let's take a
large code example.
Given the amount
of time, what I'm
going to do is
basically say, you
can go through and
figure out what
are the read after
write dependencies
and the write after
read dependencies.
They're all over the place.
And what you can
do is if you look
at what the dependencies are
that I just flashed through,
you can discover, oh,
there's all these things.
Each one right now has to
wait for the previous one
before it can get started.
But there are
some-- for example,
the first one is
just issue order.
You can't start the second--
if it's in order, you
can't start the second
till you've started
the first, that it's
finished the first stage.
But the other thing
here is there's
a data dependence between the
second and third instructions.
So if you look at the second
and third instructions,
they're both using XMM2.
And so we're prevented.
So one of the questions
there is, well,
why not do a little bit better
by taking a look at this
as a graph and
figuring out what's
the best way through the graph?
And there are a bunch of
tricks you can do there,
which I'll run through
here very quickly.
And you can take
a look at these.
You can discover that
some of these dependencies
are not real dependence.
And as long as you're willing
to execute things out of order
and keep track of that,
it's perfectly fine.
If you're not actually
dependent on it,
then just go ahead
and execute it.
And then you can advance things.
And then the other
trick you can use
is what's called
register renaming.
If you have a destination
that's going to be read from--
sorry, if I want to
write to something,
but I have to wait for
something else to read from it,
the write after read
dependence, then what
I can do is just
rename the register,
so that I have
something to write
to that is the same thing.
And there's a very
complex mechanism called
score boarding that does that.
So anyway, you can take a
look at all of these tricks.
And then the last
thing that I want
to-- so this is this part
I was going to skip over.
And indeed, I don't
have time to do it.
I just want to mention the last
thing, which is worthwhile.
So this-- you don't
have to know any
of the details of that part.
But it's in there if
you're interested.
So it does renaming
and reordering.
And then the last thing
I do want to mention
is branch prediction.
So when you come to branch
prediction, the outcome,
you can have a hazard because
the outcome is known too late.
And so in that
case, what they do
is what's called
speculative execution, which
you've probably heard of.
So basically that says I'm
going to guess the outcome
of the branch and execute.
If it's encountered,
you assume it's taken
and you execute normally.
And if you're right,
everything is hunky dory.
If you're wrong, it cost
you something like a--
you have to undo that
speculative computation
and the effect is
sort of like stalling.
So you don't want
that to happen.
And so a mispredicted
branch on Haswell
costs about 15 to 20 cycles.
Most of the machines
use a branch predictor
to tell whether or
not it's going to do.
There's a little
bit of stuff here
about how you tell about
whether a branch is
going to be predicted or not.
And you can take a look
at that on your own.
So sorry to rush a
little bit the end,
but I knew I wasn't going
to get through all of this.
But it's in the notes, in
the slides when we put it up.
And this is really kind
of interesting stuff.
Once again, remember that I'm
dealing with this at one level
below what you
really need to do.
But it is really helpful
to understand that layer
so you have a deep understanding
of why certain software
optimizations work
and don't work.
Sound good?
OK, good luck on finishing
your project 1's.